okay that's where we have climbed to
actually just some numbers money to the
cafe which is fine what is the answer
that you get out when you evaluate the
sum of the first 100 110 or you get do
you get 5151 yeah you do don't you
okay which is what we should have
expected because this plus 101 right now
here's what perplexes be about this that
I want you to think about with me we
approach the first problem by Perry okay
and then we develop the formula with
that same period strategy but then I
gave you a problem which clearly can be
paired like if you have an odd number of
times there will be that guy in the
middle right I guess in this case it
would be 51 right and you doesn't pair
up with anyone okay but the formula
still works I sort of expected to break
down in some way because when you have a
look at this see this guy over here
right and / - in your case this one we
just traded 101/2 this is not a whole
number it's 50 and a half right so it
seems like it would introduce a fraction
in the year why is that a problem why is
it a problem to introduce a fraction to
this formula for our problem there are
all whole numbers you should not have
aiding fractions but sure enough when
you evaluate it you get any fraction why
is that
oh look look look look at it
because when you own when you get by 102
by 2 the denominator of 100 and 101 -
then you get an even number Indians you
just multiply round everyone okay hold
on a second I think I get your logic but
I'm not sure where you got that 102 fro
where's the 102 from - a thousand two
hundred and - ginger - that we think is
maybe two ages just - right
so where do we come from
well we're on the right track this has
something to do with it but I think we
slightly a little bit off on the edge
just what do you think you okay so this
is this is tricky this is tricky now let
me suggest to you um the Thule does have
a hand side up has something to doing
that okay because - clearly gives you
some evenness right well that's what you
accept the really wonderful thing is
it's not just that this is even have a
look at this guy here n minus 1 right do
you remember I said to you the problem
was worse if any odd if n is odd then
the odd number divided by 2 would be a
whole number right but look at this guy
if n is odd what do you know that n
minus 1 it has to be either right this
is gonna be even this is going to be
even so if you've got even numbers in
there they're going to overcome the fact
that you've got this division by 2 does
that make sense
it's why you end up with this whole
number no matter what happens no matter
how many times you actually sleep in
this